just off camera you told us that you go
to meetup groups for writers and I'm
just wondering what meetup groups strike
your eye in terms of why you go to it
and and what do you get out of going to
well when I was first starting writing I
had some people help and give me some
advice the first writers group that I
went to that I was a part of it was all
sitcom comedy writing and the very first
notes I ever got on my first TV script
was this was so boring I was falling
asleep and and we all laughed and
because comedy writers can be can be
pretty vicious in a funny way and and
then he said when you got to this part
that's when I woke up and it was really
funny so this group showed me that right
away that you need honest feedback okay
but constructive Christmas because he
this is this particular writer he gave
me that note but then he told me what
was working so I go you know what you're
right I feel the same thing I agree with
the note and so it really helped me out
that group that little writers group I
was in eventually dissolved because
everyone got work that's a great reason
for a group to dissolve right everybody
was working on these shows so so I
thought you know it was really helpful
when I was first starting out so I
thought I'd like to help people too so I
go to the meetup site and I see those
writers group so I go to some of these
and I just give them notes you know
gentle nose encouraging notes been
honest notes and you know it's a it's
helpful to people and if you don't ever
give something back or help out other
people it that doesn't feel very good
you know
so that's okay that's your way of giving
back what do you see and I won't ask you
five things but what do you see as
several top things that most of most
writers new writers have trouble with
well the two big things are one is a
passive lead character I see that quite
a bit see it over and over
their lead character has a bunch of
people coming at them and doing things
you know saying oh you should do this
and he goes okay and he does it
it's got if it doesn't come from within
the character then you've got no train
you got no choo-choo pulling the Train
it's not pulling the story train what
you got is a caboose pushing it that
doesn't work okay you need to look it in
going somewhere and I see that a lot
just with this passive lead characters
the other thing is either no conflict or
very lower case conflict where people
are safe it's TV people are flipping
through channels and they watch
something for five six seconds if there
isn't deep conflict that's popping off
the screen they're gonna keep flipping
they're flipping past your show okay so
you like a conflict you know when you
watch TV you like it put it in your
script
one of the reasons is difficult is
because in real life people don't like
conflict if you're a nice person okay
you don't want to yell and argue with
people and you don't want to hurt
people's feelings okay but in real life
that's great in a script that's Laurie
I'm just really boring okay so let the
conflict go okay let it go into that
script put it in there and then it will
jump off the page when people read it
kind of have a passive lead character
and not enough conflict I see those two
things all the time and the other thing
that I see is people are safe I have a
professional comedy writers group and
people apply to it and we've had like a
thousand people apply in this group and
there's only 20 people in it so it's you
know we always just like certain people
to be in it it's a most of whom are
professional or their show runners and
they write for them show so and if
they're newer writers they're good and
they're all
their way and I get people applying to
the group you know perfectly nice people
people who send their script and they
have screenwriting degrees
you know sometimes multiple degrees and
in writing in theater and everything in
their script happens at exactly the
right time the exciting incident the
first act break the midpoint the third
act and all these story threads are
perfectly correct and I don't give a
crap because they were so busy being
correct in their form they haven't put
any spark of madness into the script
then put anything quirky and personal
you know and it's not in there
it's like forget all this stuff you
learn and just let it pour out just
allow your craziness your weirdness your
quirkiness to be poured into that script
that's the other mistake guys these
people they're holding back we want this
is show business okay this is the one
business where there's nothing wrong
okay you can let these characters say
weird things crazy things politically
incorrect things mean things stupid
things anything you have the license to
do an infinite number of things do it
okay so speaking of conflict let's say
the conflict was not on the script but
when you gave a note
was there ever conflict and was there
ever a time alternatively where you
thought there would be and you were
scared and actually the person thank you
yeah that's happened I mean there's
there's a way to give a note your job
when you give notes is to help the
writer tell the story they're trying to
tell to help them tell it better you say
hey this character is coming off as this
is that what is that what you meant and
they're like oh no no I meant to be
there they go oh well it's coming off
because of this and you tell them and
they they're grateful like oh I didn't
realize that you know excuse me from
little things like I was giving hosted
one person and he described it he's
described a character as elderly this
elderly character and then in the next
paragraph he called him fifty years old
you get see you're laughing and a lot of
people at the table were you know around
50 pose so I said you know what do you
say elderly we're thinking you know and
you'd say 50 right and he goes what
isn't he's a very young writer he says
wasn't that person that elderly and like
all the people were like no you know and
I said the reason this matters is
because a it's a little confusing you we
just want you want clarity in the script
and be if somebody who's reading this
you know who could hire you is 50 and
you call them elderly it's just my
create trouble right so there's little
notes like that and but I was working on
a show I came to work one day and there
was a writer who was walking out with
their stuff in a box and they had just
been let go and it was like who and we
didn't ask the executive producer
anything we didn't you know but he said
it's really nice guy this week but he
said she didn't know when to stop
defending a pitch in the room she was
perfectly nice woman everybody liked her
but when you're in the writers room in a
sitcom there's a bunch of writers there
and you'll pitch an idea
the executor said oh we need this in
this scene and you'll pitch an idea and
the exec producer will say oh yeah
that's great listen to write that or
they'll say he'll say oh that's almost
not quite and other people will pitch in
and then something pitch end like three
or four pitches later
based on your page you come up with a
solution in the script then you write
you write it or the exact person will
say no you should move on okay because
it's their job to know what's in the
show the exec producer it says that and
you don't wanna have discussions about
it and she kept defending she goes she
kept coming back to it goes well you
know if you did the thing I say and it's
like well it's it just wastes time and
it puts makes the executor feel bad
because they've got to keep saying no so
he eventually just let her go so I
learned from that that was in my career
when you're given a note like know by
your boss okay
take the note you know also sometimes
there's what's called out if you've
heard the concept the note behind
No yeah and sometimes there's something
under the note that is not clear so you
have to clarify the note for somebody
you know but it's your job if you're
gonna be notes the professionals rates
your job to explain the note until you
see the light go on in their eyes
okay that's your job to make them
understand the know you know and maybe
your note is a great note but it's not
the right note for the story they're
trying to do but when I'm working at
these meetups with newer writers and
stuff like that you take into account
that they're new you know and I've seen
a million scripts and I've solved a lot
of script problems and they haven't seen
those yet you know so you're just trying
to say hey this problem in your script
has been solved in a couple of ways by
doing this in this and how does that
feel and when you're giving the note you
can't be attached to the note if it's
not if it's not a professional stage
where if you're not their boss or
whatever you can't be attached to it you
can't get upset if they don't take your
note I mean it's not about you okay so
about the writer and their script so
there's some really fun writers at these
meetup groups there's a very talented
people of all ages you know and it's
great that they can come together and
and see their their stuff come to life
it's great that the over fifty ones
actually can get out of the house like
this I'm so glad they can make it there
yeah but I've written it I can't get up
you